salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
je vous préviens aujourd'hui on va se
faire peur je vais vous parler d'une
créature qui a semé la terreur au 18e
siècle en France tellement qu'on en
parle encore
aujourd'hui la bête du gévudan en moins
de 3 ans elle a provoqué la mort d'une
centaine de personnes s'agissait-il
réellement d'un animal à quoi
ressemblait-il et a-ton réussi à le
capturer il y a un peu de vrai et un peu
de faux dans tout ce qu'on entend on
fait le tri dans cette histoire
si ce format vous plaît n'hésitez pas à
liker cette vidéo j'ai plein d'histoires
comme celle-ci dans mes
tiroirs le 30 juin 1764 une jeune
bergère âgé de 14 ans Jeanne Boulet est
retrouvé morte près de Langogne un petit
village du
gvaudan le gvudan est une ancienne
province royale du sud de la France
France elle s'étendait sur l'actuel
département de la loosère et une partie
de la Haute Loire à l'époque c'est une
terre d'élevage très pauvre et beaucoup
moins boisé qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
paysage couvert de landes et de prairies
avec quelques forêts au milieu c'est bon
j'ai déjà peur c'est justement à la
lisière d'un petit bois que le corps
mutilé de la bergère est découvert il
est entaillé de griffur on constate
aussi de profondes morsures à première
vue ce qui crime ne peut pas être imputé
à un homme le curé de la paroisse
mentionne d'ailleurs dans son registre
que la fillette a été dévorée je cite
par la bête féroce alors s'agit-il d'un
effet de style exprimant la violence du
crime ou doit-on en conclure que la
bergère a été victime d'un animal Jeanne
boulet n'est pas la première à avoir
croisé son chemin depuis 1763 on a déjà
recensé une dizaine d'attaques étranges
dans la région il pourrait donc s'agir
du même suspect par chance les les
victimes précédant jeun boulet ont tu la
vie sauve on possède donc plusieurs
témoignages assez précis qui permettent
de décrire ce suspect et a priori il
s'agit bien d'un animal selon une
paysane qui lui a échappé de justesse la
bête ressemblerait à un loup mais un
loup XXL qui aurait la taille d'un veau
elle précise que l'animal est rou et
qu'il porte une rayur noire le long du
dos sa tête est énorme et allongée sa
gueule rempl de Croc pointu et démesuré
quant à ses yeux ils sont rouges cette
description terrifiante ne correspond à
aucun
animal le 8 août 1764 une seconde
victime est retrouvée morte encore une
gardienne de troupeau son corps est en
lambau la pauvre fille est défigurée ce
sont ses vêtements qui permettent de
l'identifier mais c'est horrible ça fait
deux agressions mortelles en un peu plus
d'un mois Mo dans la région la peur
commence à s'installer les bergers plus
menacés que les autres forment des
groupes pour ne plus être isolés on fait
aussi appel à l'armée pour tenter de
débusquer l'animal en février 1765 entre
20 et 30000 habitants hommes et femmes
sont mobilisés on organise plusieurs
battus mais en vain la bête échappe aux
poursuites malgré la traque les attaques
reprennent de plus Bell les cibles sont
toujours les mêmes de jeunes gardiens ou
gardiennes de troupeau et des enfants
isolés on les retrouve
égorgés parfois
décapité l'affaire n'échappe pas au
journaux de l'époque deux publications
le courrier d'Avignon puis la Gazette de
France s'en saisissent relatant les
découvertes macabres et informant les
lecteurs sur l'évolution de l'enquête pe
parce qu'ils avaient rien d'autre à se
mettre sous la dent en quelques jours
l'information se répand sur tout le
territoire on s'arrache les numéros
consacrés à ce fait d'hiver et à cet
animal mystérieux que l'on surnomme
désormais la bête du gvudan en à peine
un an des centaines d'articles sont
publiés dans les gazettes et pas qu'en
France la renommée de la bête dépasse
les frontières du royaume de France pour
atteindre l'Angleterre l'Espagne et les
États allemands on en parle jusqu'à San
Francisco en Amérique c'est le premier
fait d'hiver de l'histoire de dimension
internationale face à la colère du
peuple qui monte un peu partout attisé
par les journaux qui utilisent ce
prétexte pour remettre en question le
pouvoir Louis XV doit changer son fusil
d'épaule et à bien y réfléchir cette
affaire pourrait lui être utile cette
époque les finances du royaume sont dans
le rouge le pays a perdu beaucoup
d'argent avec la guerre de 7 ans qu'
l'oosait à l'Autriche et la
Grande-Bretagne pour renflouer les
caisses il s'apprête à lever un nouvel
impôt mais comment faire passer la
pilule l'affaire du gévudent tombe à
pique il offre 10000 livre à celui ou
celle qui ramènera la bête à versaill
une largesse qui devrait faire oublier
le nouveau prélèvement l'annonce ser
répend très vite et des chasseurs venus
de toute l'Europe se ruent sur le
gvudent laattque reprend mais la bête
reste insaisissable le roi ne se
décourage pas il envoie alors ses
propres chasseurs dans le gévudent mais
là encore il rentre bredouille
finalement fin septembre 1765 il
missionne son propre arquebusier
François Antoine une fine lame et alors
et bien bonne pioche le 20 septembre il
fait un retour triomphal à Versailles
avec un joli trophée la dépouille d'un
grand loup que ses hommes ont abattu son
allure et ses couleurs correspondent à
la description fournie par les témoins
on l'empaille et on l'expose fièrement
dans les jardins du roi guoui X a gagné
son Paris
ouf faut le dire vite car quelques
semaines plus tard les attaques
reprennent faisant de nouvelles victimes
les habitants de la région désespèent ni
les prières ni les âmes ne mettent fin
au cauchemar et puis le 19 juin
1767 3 ans après la première attaque
Jean Chastel un ur de la région surprend
un étrange animal son cœur bal la
chamade il ajuste son fusil aligne la
bête et vise il tremble un peu retient
son souffle pour trouver un peu de calme
car il ne faut pas louper la cible enfin
il P la et Abas un énorme animal au lieu
dit La sogne d'eau vert le spécimen est
décrit comme une créature proche du loup
avec une tête hideuse la bête est
ensuite conduite à Versailles où elle
est examinée par le célèbre iste Buffon
on a cherché mais malheureusement il n'a
laissé aucun document à ce sujet
l'animal aurait ensuite été enterré dans
le parc de Versailles où dit-on ses
ossements se trouveraient encore
aujourd'hui toujours est-il qu'à partir
de ce moment les attaqu ont cessé clap
de fin et bien non au contraire même la
légende de la bête du gevudan ne fait
que commencer pour de nombreux
spécialistes de l'affaire l'animal
abattu par Jean Chastel n'était pas le
bon la publicité faite autour de sa
capture n'aurait servi qu'à éteindre
l'incendie de nouvelles hypothèses plus
folles les unes que les autres
commencent alors à courir sur la
véritable identité du monstre on pense
par exemple que cet étrange animal
aurait servi à masquer la présence d'un
tueur en série dans la région celui-ci
aurait agi accompagné d'un gros chien
mais aucun indice ne le prouve d'autres
avancent la possibilité d'un fauve égaré
une Yenne ou un jeune lion dans cette
région à cette époque c'est quand même
peu probable à moins qu'il s'agisse d'un
animal retenu en captivité par un
aristocrate du coin qui se serait
échappé plusieurs historiens
contemporains ont également tenté de
faire la lumière sur cette étrange
affaire dans un livre intitulé Monsters
Of The gevodan l'Américain Jay a Smith
spécialiste de l'histoire de France
aimet une idée nouvelle les agressions
n'auraient pas été le fait d'un seul
animal mais d'une meute de loup
l'écrivain Bernard soulier qui lui est
originaire du village où la bête a été
abatue penche pour une autre hypothèse
celle d'un animal hybride quelque chose
entre un chien et un loup dans un livre
publié en 2010 le journaliste
Jean-Claude Bourret valide quant à lui
l'hypothèse que l'animal tué en juin
1767 serait bien la bête du Gevaudan en
2016 qu'il en propose même une
reconstitution sur la base des
descriptions faites à l'époque une
gueule monstrueuse avec des yeux rouges
bah ça me donne pas envie d'aller lui
caresser les chines à cette bestiole
aura-t-on un jour le fa mot de histoire
en attendant la bête du géudan continue
de fasciner les foules à Langogne où la
bête a fait sa première victime une
sculure de 1,20 de haut sur 2 m de long
se dresse à l'entrée de la commune le
cinéma s'en est aussi emparé au début
des années 2000 le film Le Pacte des
Loups réalisé par Christophe Gans s'est
inspiré de l'histoire de la bête il
attire à l'époque plus de 5 millions de
spectateurs un carton si vous désirez en
apprendre plus sur ce fait d'hiver il
existe une association nommée au pays de
la bête du géudan dont l'objectif est de
défendre et de faire connaître la vérité
historique à son sujet enfin pour celles
et ceux qui aiment se faire peur à saug
en reccloire un musée retrace les
aventures de cet animal mystérieux et si
vous n'avez pas assez frissonné cet
hiver il y a de quoi vous rattraper
voilà c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout j'espère ne pas vous avoir
trop effrayé ni dissuadé d'aller visiter
ces beaux départements que sont la lozè
et la Haute Loire premier juré aucun
monstre n'y a été signalé depuis plus de
200 ans à très
[Applaudissements]
bientôt